when her blood pressure drops sabina
munster's husband has to quickly respond
with emergency procedures
sabine has als amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis also known as lou gehrig's
disease
it's a motor neuron disease that leads
to debilitating disability and
eventually death
she doesn't think her life will get any
better
the medicine has hardly any effect
anymore i'm always in my wheelchair i
can barely move
it's as if i'm going through hell it's
really good again
her husband has been taking care of her
24 7 for the past seven years
but now the 55 year old has decided to
put an end to her life and she needs
help for this too
i can't just get up and go to the tenth
story of a building and jump
i would have the courage if i was
feeling bad enough but i can't even do
that
assisted suicide and euthanasia are
illegal in europe with the exception of
belgium luxembourg switzerland and the
netherlands
in germany however a person will not be
breaking the law if they help somebody
to commit suicide by providing lethal
drugs for instance
stabili for germany is an association
that campaigns for the right of people
to choose their time of death
it currently has 450 members who pay 200
euros a year in membership fees
last year 41 people committed suicide
with its help does it conclude
in concrete terms either a relative if
they're willing or a volunteer from our
association goes to the apartment of the
person in question
and administers medication that has been
prescribed by a doctor
the german parliament is trying to ban
such associations and individuals for
making money out of helping somebody to
die lawmakers from all parties generally
agree on this matter
it's my personal conviction that there's
a line that humans should not cross
sending people to their deaths or
enabling them to die
it's not acceptable that a business
model be derived from some people's
desire to put an end to their lives
it creates a risk of a climate emerging
in which people say i think i'm a burden
to my relatives to care workers and then
they behave as they imagine is expected
of them saying yes i want to end my life
i personally would prefer not to
introduce bans i have a more libertarian
approach we live in a libertarian
constitutional state and a ban would
always impinge on the rights of
self-determination of those concerned
especially
cannot afford to join an association
that helps with suicide
however she's found somebody online
whose services are cheaper
this man does it more or less on a
voluntary basis only covering his costs
he does it for human and humanitarian
reasons
here
someone else would say he's a murderer
but to me he's a savior
professionals who work in hospices and
provide palliative care say that these
need more support and funds
germany's parliament is currently
looking into the matter
often people's desire to die comes from
a sense of despair
from the feeling of being badly cared
for
we have to increase the number of places
in hospices
and have to support people so they don't
fall into such despair
and then contact those organizations
because they
we know that palliative medicine is the
preferred answer to pain but we provide
an answer to those very few people for
whom palliative medicine is no
takes pills every three hours the pain
is still almost unbearable
i don't want to just die somewhere in a
bed
every dog is granted the right to die
we let him go to sleep when he's
suffering
this right isn't granted to people
even if they know they're going toward a
slow cruel and painful death
when advice are lost in ireland rousseau
belong them quite far
anyone who's as ill as i am should be
granted this right
this has nothing to do with the third
reich and euthanasia times have changed
hitler and goebbels are no longer around
her husband says he was shocked the
first time she told him she wanted to
die
but he stopped trying to talk her out of
it
we had long discussions and some of them
were very controversial
but when i realized what a terrible
illness my wife has
i understood that she was being
reasonable
but of course it took a long time for me
to accept this
they say that they will call the person
who will help sabine munster commit
suicide when she can no longer turn
around in her bed
i'm already in hell with my pain
things can only get worse from here